We are the New York Knicks,
We are the New York Knicks .
Say go New York,
go New York,
go.
Go New York,
go New York,
go.
Say go New York,
go New York.
Joining me today is a New York Times
bestselling author,
the guy who wrote that mid nineties,
New York Knicks,
anthem,
a man who has founded enterprises from
private jet companies to Zico coconut
water.
The Co owner of the MBA's Atlanta Hawks
and Oh,
a former rapper Jesse Itzler.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me,
dude.
Your bio is like,
like it doesn't even seem like it could
possibly be real.
It's been quite a journey.
Quite a journey.
There's so much I want to do with you.
I said to you right before we started,
I mean I remember that 94 nick's team so
well that was like right in my formative
years of basketball,
which I love.
I said to you right before we started
that that game six,
which as an expat is probably one of the
most painful things you ever watched.
A was the night of my senior prom and of
course the night of the Oj Simpson car
chase.
You lived through that whole experience.
I did.
I was at the Knick game that night.
I was at the Knick game.
It was a playoff game.
I just written the theme song for the
Knicks and started was starting to get
momentum on the radio and in the garden
and I was so,
I mean my whole life up a knick fan and
it also was a big moment and here we
are,
game six at home and all of a sudden the
Oj Chase,
I was getting like a pretzel.
I went outside,
I was just looking at the monitor and I
looked up.
I'm like,
what in the world is this?
Oh Wow.
So they were showing you don't go out to
the concessions.
It was on the Monitor.
So you know,
I was conflicted and people were running
back and forth.
It was wild.
Yeah.
What a crazy night because the,
the rangers had just won the Stanley Cup
finals I think,
and it was just like a great time to be
in New York.
Then Oj obviously people must've been
talking about my prom so I can only
imagine what was going on over there.
All right,
so speaking of New York,
you're from Roslyn Long Island.
I'm from syosset Long Island.
We're about 10 minutes away from each
other on the long island expressway.
I find that a lot of interesting people
come out of long island had.
Have you found that?
Is that the water?
What's going on?
You know,
it's crazy.
I was told I was actually just having
this conversation the other day with a
friend of mine and I was saying in my
town,
if you took the year that I graduated my
senior year and went back for years and
forward four years,
so in that eight year gap or whatever it
is from,
you know,
of kids that went through my school.
We have A.
I think we have to with three
professional sports team owners.
We have multiple billionaires.
I have five guys that I went to high
school is that are in jail.
We've had multiple suicides and Bernie
madoff was from my town.
So I look at my town and think that
everybody had the same opportunity.
Same teachers.
We had one movie.
I mean it was a small,
relatively small town.
One,
one real high,
one high school that everyone went to.
A real sense of community.
Everyone had the same basically,
you know,
journey through with as far as teachers
and everything.
Yet we had this crazy swing of the
biggest Ponzi schemer and his,
his family and sons were in our school,
you know,
guys that were super successful.
People that had super successful parents
that went to jail,
I mean,
all in this community.
And it was like,
Whoa,
what was in the water in this town?
What do you make of that actually,
because there's gotta be something
there.
I mean,
even my high school,
I mean there,
I knew a couple people that I went to
high school with that ended up in jail,
but we also had judd apatow into my high
school.
Idina Menzel.
Huge Broadway star.
Natalie Portman.
Yeah.
Until my high school and all sorts of
things.
I think that I feel very lucky that I
grew up in a town that I grew up in and
the area that we grew up in that,
um,
you know,
it was,
it was diverse.
There was a lot of opportunity,
there was creativity.
It wasn't far from the city.
So we had like a little bit of the city
vibe.
Is that what it is?
I think it has something to do with the
proximity because we were about 45
minutes away from New York City.
Most of our parents,
I'm guessing maybe your parents who
worked in New York City,
so there was like a little bit of a
commuter thing,
but you weren't totally part of New
York.
Like something related to that.
I think that's part of it.
I think for me,
I think it's just the time period that I
grew up,
you know,
as a kid and there was just a change in
music change in culture and we would
just expose being close to the city.
We had early exposure to all those
trends and we were early to the party
and I think that had a big impact,
at least it did for me.
I know as an entrepreneur and in my
journey,
it was exciting.
There was always exciting.
I wanted to be part of everything.
So you know,
I got addicted to newness because there
was always something new going on and
that fueled me even going forward.
So I feel very lucky that,
you know,
we grew up where we did.
Anything else I should know about your
formative years are family before we get
into some of the things that you,
uh,
not.
No,
you can ask me.
All right,
well if there's,
if there's nothing else specific you
said addicted to newness.
So I feel this is the right time to play
a little clip from you as a rapper known
as Jesse James.
Lovely.
Sounds like a good one.
Let me get my keys.
She said how was the pain of saying
don't even try it.
I pulled through.
I love it,
but Nah,
she didn't.
She was laid off.
Wow.
Oh Man.
Jesse James.
That wasn't in the uh,
in the email that you sent me about the
shelf there.
You're going to flash back.
We have a pretty crack research team
around here.
We're going full flashback before we get
to the future and the present.
How did that happen?
Like I said,
grew up in long island in the eighties,
you know,
and hip hop was comment was emerging.
I got really into it at an early age and
then when I was in college,
you know,
I went,
everybody was writing their resumes and
sending out resumes.
I was like,
I'm going to try to make a record,
like,
this is what I want to do.
And um,
there was no b plan and ultimately,
you know,
that passion really for three years of
college I was working towards trying to
get a record deal and ultimately landed
a deal with a company called delicious
vinyl out in Cali,
not far from where we are.
And they had two big accidents and they
had a guy named tone loke wild thing
called Medina.
And then they had had a little bit of a
tone loke feel to it that same
producers.
And then we had a young Mc who won a
grammy for bust a move.
So I was able to,
uh,
I,
I didn't know that,
but literally I was watching it this
morning and I said to David,
my producer that it's,
that's what it sounded like.
Yeah,
it's the same guys,
same year,
same time and uh,
and put an album out in the early
nineties.
Wow.
So I was watching it and I was thinking
man,
time changes,
you know,
things change,
we get sensitive to different things,
but I would guarantee it.
But if a young guy like you put that
song out now talking about a white woman
in a white rapper,
we'd have a certain amount of people
screaming about cultural appropriation
and all sorts of other stuff.
Was that even remotely something back
then?
Well,
you know,
I think it was,
it wasn't on my mind,
but the shaker,
like a white girl was my first single
was actually a remake,
the title of an old EU song or an old
Bogos song from abandoned Washington dc
that was predominantly all black.
So I felt like I was just kind of taking
the momentum of this hit song and
introducing it to the theme to.
It was fun.
I was in college,
I was,
I wrote the whole album basically,
you know,
as a fraternity in my fraternity house.
And um,
yeah,
it was pretty tongue and cheek.
Yeah,
it kind of makes you wish that things
were as simple as they were back then.
Right?
Because you could,
could you,
are you following me on this?
Like I can just see like some fraternity
kid doing something silly like that now
and just like getting just like a ton of
shit for it.
Even if it was totally good natured and
all that,
it was totally good natured.
But I look back on it now and I think,
you know,
if I were to go back in time I probably
would do a lot of things differently
just based on what I know now and you
know,
I'm turning 50 so I'm very aware of,
you know,
what chapter I am in my life,
but when I looked back at me at 21 and
what I knew then and you know,
all of the mistakes,
I made a 21.
Uh,
but you know,
it's part of the growth and part of the
journey.
Yeah.
Alright.
So I want to get to some of the growth
and the journey.
I want to get to cook and all that
stuff.
But wait,
let's just jump back to the,
to the go New York,
go New York,
go.
How in the world did that even appear
that you are going to be the guy that
wrote that thing and were you shocked
that it caught on?
I mean,
the video which we'll uh,
we'll also link to down below.
I like,
I remember every moment of that.
So what happened for me is right after
college,
no resume,
you know,
got rejected by a lot of record labels.
I had no context.
My Dad owned a plumbing supply house in
Mineola also now we had,
I didn't know anyone that was connected
to anything,
so I had to take this whole,
this whole process on my own shoulders
and I would literally take a greyhound
bus on Friday from Washington dc where I
went to school with my demo tape,
which was a recording of an instrumental
that I played on my cd player and I
would hit record on my answering machine
and leave a wrap to the music while it
was playing.
That was out.
The only way I can man.
Unbelievable.
Like,
that just sounds like a time warp.
I know that was the only way I could do
it.
I would show up and handout that
cassette to everybody and got rejected.
But ultimately I did get a record.
I get it.
I didn't get a record deal and um,
but that was my only goal.
So I took my foot off the gas pedal once
I got the deal and I didn't get signed
for a second album,
which to me was crushing at the time
because the only thing on my resume now
was failed rapper,
you know,
I was also a Kiddie pool attendant
before there.
So that wasn't really going to get me a
job on Wall Street.
That's like a low level.
Like whoa.
Like training,
know no walk,
no peeing.
That was,
if you could say walk and stop,
stop peeing.
You can get the job.
They're always paying no matter.
There's nothing you to get them out of
that.
But in any event,
I wanted to stay,
even though I didn't get picked up for a
second album,
I wanted to marry my two passions,
which was sports and music.
And I had this idea to write a theme
song for the Knicks.
I was like,
all of a sudden sports,
we're changing.
The game is only 48 minutes and you're
there,
you're a fan for 48 minutes,
but for the other two hours that you're
in the arena during timeouts,
you're an audience.
And the teams had to entertain the
audience.
And now they brought in the dancers.
The dancers came in and they had video
boards that all of a sudden never
existed.
So I was like,
let's do a theme song.
Like the bears did a song in 86,
let's do a theme song,
will get all the celebrities involved in
and maybe you'll catch on.
So I wrote this demo basically in my
apartment,
which was like a dorm room and I played
it for the next.
And,
uh,
had you even get that meeting I had,
I started doing jingles.
Uh,
and somehow I did a jingle for Nancy
Grunfeld clothing company or husband
Ernie was the GM and she loved the
jingle and I said,
well,
Nancy,
if you love this,
let's,
let's do something for the next,
let's try this.
So she said,
I'll take a shot at.
So I just did it on Spec.
I walked in and I knew there was
something there and I played it for them
and they said,
you know,
we'll,
we'll give you a $40,000
for the song.
And I said,
okay.
And I hired a right then and there you
said okay,
right then and there.
Oh yeah,
no lawyer,
no,
I didn't ask any questions of $40,000.
It was eight months of rent.
So I,
um,
when I hired a lawyer,
ultimately I needed a lawyer,
studio engineer,
Singer,
drummer,
producer,
et cetera.
It costs me $4,800
to do this song.
But every team that came into Madison
Square Garden and said,
why don't we have a theme so this and
the next got hot and it became the
number one most requested song.
That little jingle on New York radio.
And I realized like that's the white
space,
nobody else is.
Everyone's trying to get on MTV and get
their records and tower records.
But no,
there's a category,
a new category that I could create
sports,
music,
and I started doing theme songs for
professional sports teams.
It's so awesome.
Like it's just such a great story of
just like a kid,
basically a kid just like it over there,
just get out there and do something.
It's kind of,
it's kind of a beautiful thing.
You must look at it back.
I can see sort of in your face,
like there's like a nostalgia to it
because it was just like,
it was what it was.
I look at it from that chapter of my
life where I had 21 years old I had,
there were no consequences.
Like if I didn't get this song,
I would have gone to the next team and
kept.
I was so deeply connected to my dream,
like emotionally connected to the goal
that I was on greyhound bus every day
dry.
I mean I would do anything.
So just to have the opportunity that it
was just everything else was gravy.
Yeah.
So,
so is that really where the
entrepreneurial spirit started with you
because it seems like you've got that
going and then that opened up a whole
slew of other doors that opened up the
floodgates for some big,
for some big future successes and
failures.
But I was thinking about this actually
yesterday on a run.
You know,
I used to.
You'll probably remember,
I don't know if you're into tennis,
but the US Open was right by,
you know,
you can take.
Oh yeah,
flushing,
yes.
We would just take the train.
There were no rules.
My,
my parent's home by 8:00
at night,
I would take the train and I remember I
would never have a ticket and all I
could look,
I would look forward to being able to
try to sneak into the US Open and I
remember that,
that I've kind of figured out how to
sneak into the u s open regularly.
So I would go no ticket,
everyone's online and I would go to like
how I went in and then I would walk out
and see if I could do it again somewhere
else.
And that was really the start of like,
as I look back,
like I just want,
I like challenges.
It doesn't,
it's not about anything other than can I
figure it out and,
and it started for me at an early age
and ultimately it gravitate,
you know,
it started to gravitate towards
business.
So let's,
let's get there.
So,
okay,
you're making the jingles,
some things happen.
You're obviously making money,
probably some serious money for the
first time.
How does this get you to starting
incubators and starting these companies.
So every team that came into Madison
Square Garden say,
why don't we have a song like this who
did this?
And I was the guy.
So I started writing all these 10 songs
and ultimately sold that company to a
public company called SFX.
And the owner of SFX had a timeshare in
a private jet.
And he invited was like 26 years old and
he invited my partner and I as guests
onto his private jet and it was like the
scene in the wizard of Oz when we walked
on the plane,
when everything goes from black and
white,
I walked on the plane,
I'm like,
people fly like this,
and by the time we landed,
my partner turned to me,
he's like,
we got to start a private jet company so
we can fly around on these planes.
And I was like,
let's do it.
That's all there is.
And that's literally how we started this
company that ultimately be called.
I was called Marquis jet that,
um,
became the largest private jet car
company in the world.
So you eventually sold the company.
It's called nest yet?
No,
it was called Marquis jet.
And you sold it to Warren Buffett's
Netjet,
which is a Berkshire hathaway company.
And then.
So then now you're rolling in bill.
Um,
it was,
it was a change,
definitely a life changing moment for
me.
Um,
but again,
I love newness and I was a at that time
in my life I had just ran 100 mile run
for charity and I gave myself 90 days to
train for it and during the process of,
of my training,
I discovered coconut water because I did
a lot of research around hydration and
nutrition.
If you're going to run 24,
100 miles nonstop,
what do you,
what do you drink and how many calories
you take in and you're experimenting
with that with that now through your new
diet which you're going through.
But I discovered coconut water and which
ultimately fueled me for this race that
I completed.
And when I was done I was like,
man,
this is the fountain of Youth.
This is going to be the next big thing
in beverage,
you know,
it's like,
this is the next orange juice,
this is the next poem.
Wonderful.
And I spent a year traveling the globe
trying to figure out how to import
coconut water.
Where,
where yours is.
This is a 2007,
2007.
So like was money because it's not that
long ago.
And yet,
coconut orders so massive right now
you'd think this would have to be 25
years ago,
but in 2007,
it wasn't even on the show.
There was one skew on the shelf,
wasn't,
it?
Didn't really exist.
Uh,
but I realized that the learning curve,
I got like a 90 on my sat.
The learning curve was 1200.
Okay.
All right.
I'm old ones.
I should have called you.
I couldn't figure it out,
man.
I'm like,
I know I can market this,
but like I don't know how I'm going to
import this and so many moving pieces.
So I ended up partnering with a company
that was a,
you know,
on the scene called Zico just doing a
couple million dollars in sales.
And then ultimately two years later we
sold it to cook.
So then,
then you're really in the business
world.
Like at that point you've sold two
companies and,
and your role and how,
how do you then go,
all right,
I like newness.
What's new after this?
Because that's what your story seems to
be.
It's just like another.
What's new,
what's new,
what's new?
But I get bored easily and I just,
you know,
I,
I believe in checking the box and like
not celebrating what happened,
happened,
what's next?
And you know,
my whole thing,
I always talk about this,
it's just about building my own personal
life resume,
not even my business resume.
And Like I love adventure.
So I was just looking for whatever that
next opportunity was and it became,
it was for me at the time,
light of my life.
The next thing was a book,
but it wasn't planned.
It wasn't planned.
Let's,
let's talk about that book a little bit
before we get to this book.
Yeah.
I was at a,
uh,
at a race,
a 24 hour race.
I love endurance.
I participate in a lot of endurance
events.
And um,
the race was,
was a really,
really format.
So I was a five friends and each runs a
mile and you rotate and whatever team
runs the most amount of miles in 24
hours wins the competition.
But at the start of the race,
there was a guy sitting next to us,
had no one to really with.
He had no teammates.
He was his own team and he weighed like
285 pounds,
big African American guy just sitting in
a chair.
Everything to myself.
How in the world is a guy that weighs
two 85 going to run for 24 straight
hours and the race was uncertain?
Are you even allowed to.
They let you run a relay.
One guy,
it was like the always so low,
you know,
by himself and it was just like.
And it was just so big and eating and
the race was unsupported so they,
they provide nothing.
It was on a dirt one mile,
unlit parking lot.
And you hadn't even bring their own
water.
I mean they gave you nothing.
So I had just sold my company.
I like,
I went crazy on our side.
The seuss is a table set up like 10.
This guy had three items,
a box of crackers,
a fold up chair and a bottle of water.
And I was like,
man,
this isn't going to work out well.
And sure enough,
at mile 70,
he,
because of his weight,
he had broken multiple bones in both of
his feet.
He crushed the bones in his feet and
he's from just the pounding because he
was just so big and because the only had
water and crackers,
he had kidney failure.
He was peeing blood down his leg and my
first reaction is,
man,
we gotta get this guy a medic
immediately like airlift and add here to
a hospital.
Boy Did he do.
He gets out of the chair,
picks himself up,
runs another 30 miles to get to his goal
of 100 and then runs one more in case
they miscounted and I immediately was
like,
man,
I gotta I gotTa meet this guy.
I got to meet him because whatever
secret sauce he has,
like whatever drive he has to get them
out,
get them out of the chair.
You don't even get a ribbon for funding
like pat you on the back.
Good job.
There's no trophy.
You don't get extra crackers.
No.
This was like go home and that's that.
Whatever got them out of the chair.
If I could teach that to my kids,
if I could apply that drive to the
multiple buckets of my life,
then all the areas of my life would be
so much better.
So I ended up call,
you know,
googling.
I'm founding.
It was a navy seal.
I cold called them and we sat down for
lunch and I realized I would never get
the secret sauce in a lunch meeting and
just ask them like,
would you come live with me for a month?
And he said to me,
I'm basically direct quote,
if you're crazy enough to ask a guy like
me to come live with you,
mother Fucker,
I'm crazy enough to come.
And that was the start of our journey.
So you've spent how much time you spent
a month?
He came and moved into with my wife
Sarah,
myself,
and at the time my son had one child.
We should mention his name because let's
give him the credit.
David Goggins,
David Goggins.
He's an amazing human,
uh,
an American.
And I'm with an amazing story.
Came and lived with my wife and I and my
son for $8 for 30 days.
Or what did your wife think about this?
I'm bringing a navy seal and for a month
she called me after the lunch meeting
and she said,
you know,
how did it go?
And I said,
very quickly isn't live with us.
She got into a big fuss.
I said,
no,
he's sweet.
He's coming to live with us on Friday.
And um,
no,
I mean she wants,
he came in,
they immediately took to each other and
it was just an amazing journey.
And then I never thought the notion of
writing a book never crossed my mind.
In fact,
the book came out,
the booklet living with the seal came
out five years after he actually lived
with us.
Um,
because as I started to put some of the
tools that I,
I learned what I learned about myself
and about his mindset into action and
share it with others.
I was like,
well,
there's something here.
And that's sort of how it came to
fruition.
Yeah,
let's explore some of that stuff.
So he gets to your house first day,
like,
did you have a plan or were you just
take over man,
you got a month?
Like,
make me better.
I said to,
uh,
make yourself at home is the first thing
I said to him and I said,
you know,
our home is your home.
And he walked right over to me and he
said,
I don't have a home as you know,
make yourself at home.
It's just an expression.
And again,
it got a little closer,
like nose to nose.
And he said,
I don't operate in expressions as like a
great little,
great 30 day house guest.
And he said,
in fact,
get your stuff on.
Let's go see where you're at.
Physically will go down to the gym so I
can map out the month.
And when he came to live with us at that
time in my life,
I was in a great spot.
You know,
I was married,
I'm still married,
um,
had just had a child and now for had
some failure,
had some success.
But I was in,
I thought I was in a really good spot.
But like so many of us,
I was in a routine now,
it was really comfortable in my routine.
My routine was get up,
work out hard,
go to work all day,
come home,
have some dinner with my wife and child,
little bit of alone time repeat.
And like I thought I was operating up
here but I was so comfortable I couldn't
get out of it.
And like you routines are great but they
can also be a Rut.
Like I realized like I don't want to go
through life like this.
Like I want to go through life like
this.
I got to get out of my routine man,
otherwise I'm going to wake up and I'll
be 70.
So you think that that routine,
even when it's all going well and it
sounds like things were going pretty
well for you,
that no matter what,
that level of routine will automatically
stifle creativity without question and,
and time goes fast.
Like I have four kids,
I want to slow the clock down.
Yeah.
And if I'm in routine and your routine,
you miss a lot of opportunities,
at least for me,
that's the way I've found my life to
unfold.
And I feel like when I stepped out of
routine,
you know,
when I go into the unknown,
that's where amazing growth happens and
that's where I feel most alive and
that's where I get the most benefit and
that's why it's a check the box and move
on mentality.
And that's what this opportunity was for
me.
Nothing other than to,
you know,
to step into the unknown.
He represented unknown and a and a
little bit of secret sauce.
So we'd go down to my gym and you know,
he's like,
let me see how many posts you can do.
So I got up and I,
you know,
I can run pretty far in a circle or a
straight line for a long time but not
really strong.
So I did like a,
like eight pull ups,
which is an exaggeration,
like for like two bullets.
And then he started wait 30 seconds and
do it again.
So I got back on the bar and I did
again,
like one or two or something,
you know,
barely.
He said,
wait 30 seconds,
I want you to do it again.
And now like my arms are like I get back
on the bar and I'm trying to get my chin
up over the bar.
And I dropped down and I started,
well what's next?
And he said,
well what's next is we're not leaving
here until you do 100 more Jesus.
And I said,
that's impossible.
I can't do 100.
And he said to me,
well,
I already know what your biggest problem
is,
but probably with all of our biggest
problem is.
And he said,
I'm the limitations that you're putting
on herself that we put on ourselves are
self imposed and I'm going to prove it
to you.
So get back up on fucking bar and give
me a pull up.
So I did a pull up and I dropped down
and I repeated that process until I did
all hundred holy.
And I realized it took like two hours.
But I realized at that moment that if
I'm under indexing by 100 pull ups,
like what are the areas of my life and
my under indexing it,
you know,
am I under indexing at work with my wife
and my relationships?
Am I comfortable,
am I in this routine?
I mean,
I just didn't want to go to that place
of pain to see what I was really made up
and that started our journey and that
was a constant theme of like,
how far can you take this,
Jesse?
Like,
you know,
why are you holding yourself back?
And not physically but in,
in everything,
in work.
Okay.
You've had some success,
but how do you know your limits?
It's like when I started running,
my goal was to run two miles.
If I could run two miles in 18 minutes,
I consider myself a runner and that was
it.
And I worked hard to get.
Took me weeks to go from the couch to
those two miles.
There's a lot of people with a gun to
their head.
They can run two miles right now.
Nothing changed in my body since then.
Same legs,
same long as God gave me saying I'm not
really strong,
but I was able to take that same body
guy gave me from two miles and
ultimately take it to 100 miles without
stopping and the only thing that changed
was what I thought I could do.
So if I was under indexing 50 x in that
area again,
what am I limits in business,
what am I limits in my life resume and
how I live my life and what am I limits
and how deep my relationships can be and
what am I limits in how much I can learn
and we're travel or anything.
So I think it's probably easy for people
at some level to understand the
quantifiable stuff.
I can run faster,
I can lift more,
that kind of stuff.
Could you talk about it sort of on the
mental side,
on the relationship side,
like how do you actually judge what are
the right ways to spread yourself in
those areas?
Sure.
Well,
I mean I think that.
I think for me,
I think a lot of people and we think
about relationships.
We think of relationships between
people.
How is your relationship with your
parents or your child or your husband or
wife or whatever it is,
and I think one thing that's often very
neglected is our relationship with time
and talk about quantifiable stuff and
I'm very aware of my relationship with
time.
That's been a fundamental shift for me
over the last couple of years and maybe
because I've turned 50,
but I was recently on a,
on a camping trip.
You look like you're 28.
He's doing something right.
We don't know man,
it's,
it's long island,
but I was recently on a camping trip and
I was with a friend of mine as a police
officer and stuff.
The Kennedy County.
He had his daughter.
I had my son and we went on a on a cold
winter now,
Washington blizzardy outdoor,
sleeping in the snow camping trip and I
turned to him and I said,
Cathy,
how often do you do trips like this?
This is a guy that's a police officer.
You know,
one of the happiest guys I know,
probably not super well off.
I mean,
you know,
a blue collar guy,
extremely happy and he says,
I take.
He said every year I take one trip a
year with my college friends.
I've been doing it for 21 years old.
Then every other month I take a trip
with my family or myself.
It'd be running a marathon.
It could be go to the lake,
it could be going on a hike,
whatever.
And I said to myself,
if I can't take,
I call it Kevin's rule,
one weekend every eight weeks for my own
adventure with my family,
with friends and doesn't have to be
something that costs a lot of money.
But if I can think five or six of those
a year,
then I'm way out of balance.
So it might not be a direct answer to
your question,
but what I'm saying is,
you know,
you,
you could in the past maybe that would
be one or two times a year and I
wouldn't even be aware of it.
But once you become aware of it,
look over the next 30 years you're
talking about 150 memories.
You know,
it's all cumulative as opposed to maybe
20,
30 memories.
That's the difference of like a really
full life.
It could be at the end of the day with
no regrets,
with no regrets versus someone that's in
their routine going through life like
this and then you wake up and you're 75
and you're like,
fuck,
I don't have the energy to go to Mt.
Washington anymore.
I don't have my son.
My kids are grown up,
so those kinds of shifts are measurable
and I can pinpoint in time,
I can pinpoint into my relationship with
my wife and just Friday night dinners,
Wednesday night,
date night.
It's just,
what's your relationship with time?
How do you spend it?
Who Do you spend it with and are you
doing the things you love to do?
Yeah.
Well that's definitely a good segue to
living with monks so quickly though.
Do you have some of those people in your
life where Kevin just said about
reconnect with the high school friends
and that.
Because I find now a couple of my most
valuable relationships that I have right
now are with.
One of them's my,
my childhood best friends since,
um,
since we were four years old,
I remember meeting the guy and in
kindergarten and I think it,
maybe it was the day before kindergarten
and then another friend from third grade
and we've stayed connected and because
of that it helps me frame the future
because we've been having these same
conversations about love and life and
sports and politics forever.
And it's like watching us all,
you know,
one of them lives in jersey,
ones in,
in Texas and I'm here in La and yet our
journeys,
they still matter to each other.
So I think it helps set the future sort
of.
Yeah,
I'm fortunate that I do,
uh,
I'm so,
you know,
so,
so at the same high school friends and
friends from my neighborhood when I grew
up,
still super close to.
And I think you're right,
you know,
we're so lucky to have that.
And uh,
it's still a big part of my life that
those relationships and also,
you know,
they can relate to the back story very
often.
If I meet someone now they know Jesse at
50,
they don't know Jesse.
It's six and Roslyn little league and
they don't know Jesse,
you know,
we,
we probably a year,
a couple of years older,
we probably played little league against
each other.
You got a couple of years.
Okay.
Right,
right,
right.
But same thing.
Um,
so I agree with you.
I agree with you and,
but you know,
I,
I think all of my friends from high
school and even college and even today,
I mean they invest time and keeping
those relationships so,
and you can do it easily now through
facebook and social media and this kind
of stuff,
but often we don't.
But I'm fortunate that my group of
friends,
we do,
you know,
we had for awhile,
we have a newsletter that we put
together for each other and um,
it makes me smile just thinking about it
now.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
just feel really lucky.
Alright,
so let's shift to your new book,
living with the monks.
I want to get the subtitle totally right
here because I love it.
What?
Turning off my phone taught me about
happiness,
gratitude,
and focus.
So we are taping this right now.
We're holding it for a little bit
because I want to air this right before
I go off the grid because my audience
knows I do this.
August off the grid thing,
literally locked my phone and it's safe.
No phone,
no TV,
no electronics,
no nothing.
I'm going to work on my book a little
bit.
I'll probably escape to a beach for a
little bit.
I'm not even totally sure what I'm going
to do,
but just get off the endless information
grid.
So before we talk about me and why I
think it's good to do that.
What led you to wanting to do this first
place?
Well,
I'd spent.
I'd invested so much in the physical
side for my whole life,
you know,
running marathons and doing endurance
events and had a navy seal move in with
me,
but I really had felt like I had
neglected the inner side and just the
inner work and I was just going so fast.
So I felt too to really,
again,
maybe I'm turning to gold,
but I don't know,
but to get the whole package or that
what I want and be as well rounded,
I really needed that side is the
spiritual side.
And um,
and I was just thinking like,
well who would be the best teacher?
And I thought monks and I didn't know
anything about monks other than like
watching some movies,
you know,
fringe articles here and there.
I thought that'd be really cool to learn
about,
you know,
the traditions and how amongst lived
their lives.
And I'm doing exactly what you said.
You know,
I'm,
I'm bombarded by information and I don't
spend any time alone.
And when you don't spend time alone,
you lose your super power.
Use your intuition because you're being
influenced by everybody else and you
don't exercise your gut muscle.
I was losing my superpower.
So I said to Sarah,
I think I want to go in.
And
was there a moment that you really felt
that you had lost it or that you could
really recognize that you lost?
Because I think a lot of people walk
around with that all the time now.
I just,
because the endless social media,
you're so hit with stuff constantly that
it does make your,
your sort of inner monologue sort of
harder to listen to because it's just
being slammed in every which direction.
It was a buildup.
I just felt so distracted.
Yeah.
And you know,
we all feel overwhelmed.
I mean,
but I felt really distracted and I felt
like,
you know,
I have four kids a job,
I'm married friends.
My parents are getting older.
I mean all of these different things.
And then all these different social
media things and news and Netflix and
Hulu about like,
I just want to,
like,
I got to just be alone.
And so it was a buildup and then my wife
and I were talking about it as they just
want to,
I'm going to go and live in a monastery.
And she was super encouraging,
you know,
and she was like,
um,
so,
so that's what happened.
So what do you,
do?
You give her a call,
you yellow,
the yellow thing?
Yeah.
Yes.
Siri,
I,
um,
I actually found this monastery through
a friend of mine who was actually my
publisher and I went to a monastery with
eight monks,
which already was a misconception for me
because I thought monastery meant
community meant hundreds,
but there were eight months at this
particular monastery for which had been
there for 50 years.
Wow.
And they lived on 500 acres in the
states,
but in isolation,
500 acres and similar to what you're
about to do in,
in August or now.
Um,
you know,
no phone,
no Internet,
no news,
no this,
no that,
uh,
and I just took 15 days to decompress.
So what was it like?
So you get there day one.
I mean,
what was the most shocking part I got
since you were a pretty open guy.
So there was probably not much that
could shock you.
But like what do they say?
Do they take all your stuff?
First of all,
they were Russian Orthodox.
They weren't Buddhist.
So like that era,
I didn't,
I had no expectation of anything.
And um,
I walked into my room,
which they call a cell.
That's the rooms are called sales and
monastery and it was the size of this
carpet like where we are and I had a
bed,
one little desk with a light and brother
Christopher who is like my go to monk a
sat me down and he said,
tomorrow at 7:00
AM,
we'll start with prayer,
reflect,
reflection and meditation.
And I said,
okay,
it's 6:00
PM,
what do I do next?
Thirteen hours.
And he looked at me and he said,
you think?
And I said,
okay.
And he left the room and I realized
like,
I can't call my wife.
I can't.
There's no books in my room.
I mean they had books but there are no
books.
There's no like,
it's super like required.
And I'm like,
alright,
I'm going to,
I'm going to meditate.
Let me start the journey.
I took a TM,
transcendental meditation course,
set my timer for 20 minutes.
I sat in my chair and I started to close
my eyes,
focused on that mantra and I'm getting
bombarded.
Boy,
how am my kids,
my wife,
you know,
the hawks are going to be,
what are we going to do this?
Everything's going through my head and
we will talk about the hawks were done
by the way.
I'm sitting and I'm going and I'm like,
why isn't my beeper beep because I've
been here forever and I'm like,
I probably didn't start it,
so let me just keep going,
keep going.
And finally there's no beep.
And I said,
well,
let me just reset my beeper and I'll
start over though.
I go back.
That will be cheating.
Anyway,
I in my chair forever and I finally
like,
this is ridiculous.
I'll just let me reset this and start
this again.
And I opened up my eyes.
I looked at my time or three minutes and
27 seconds.
Wow.
And I calculated how many minutes I have
left on the monastery.
I did 15 days,
times 24 times.
And I was like,
wow.
I just said to myself,
I'm fucked like this is,
this is great on paper in theory,
but this is gonna be fucking hard.
And I just sat in my room and I was
like,
oh my God,
what did I get myself into?
Were you allowed to leave the room?
I couldn't leave the room,
I couldn't leave the property.
This is the craziest situation.
So the monks to keep the lights on at
the monastery,
they breed German shepherds.
So there were 11 adult German shepherds,
eight monks and nick.
So they're selling German shepherd
puppies and they trained dogs.
They're world renown dog trainers,
world's,
they've written books,
they've sold millions of copies of
books.
They're just,
it's just a really unusual scenario.
So yes,
I could leave my cell and walk around
the monastery,
but first of all,
it's 40 degrees outside.
It's,
there's no lights.
It's like pitch dark at 4:00.
It's freezing.
There's bear according to the monks,
like.
So,
no,
I really couldn't leave.
So I mean I just kinda like,
um,
I ended up walking 120 miles up and down
the driveway they had because I had to
get some exercise over the course of my
journey,
but I didn't,
I didn't leave.
So,
um,
I just sat there and you know,
the first five days,
five days was really,
really difficult for me and I started
immediately doing probably what I think
most people do.
Certainly what I do,
I started giving myself an out.
I started justifying that it will be
okay to go home early,
just seven days,
man,
that's enough.
Get out of here in seven days.
No one's gonna say,
oh you didn't do whatever.
And I started creating all these excuses
in my head and I started thinking about
like,
what are the goals do I have in areas of
my life and my giving excuses in,
you know,
and really started to like analyze
everything that was going through my
head and put it into out the real my
real world.
And I just saw a lot of things about
myself,
you know,
through the,
through just being quiet and alone.
How did you break through that moment of
I can get away with seven days here.
Like what was the actual thing that
turned down that I have a two words that
changed my life,
that I refer back to all the time and
I'm the.
When I wanted to go home,
those two words were like,
I signed up for 15 days.
That's what,
that's what this goal was 15 days,
day five when I really want to go home
and I missed my kids and I couldn't call
them.
You know,
the two words are,
remember tomorrow when you have a big
split second decision or a big major
decision,
how,
how is that decision going to make you
feel tomorrow?
So I said to myself,
if I drop out and quit now,
the one time I'm going to do this in my
life,
how am I going to feel about this
tomorrow when I get home?
When someone says,
how'd you do?
Did you make it terrible?
You know,
my legs are swollen at mile 18,
I want to drop out of the race.
So the marathon,
but I don't want to come home the next
day after the New York marathon.
Did you finish?
So remember tomorrow.
So I just kind of said that to myself
over and over,
like just remember how you gonna feel
about this and remember how proud you're
going to feel at the end of the journey.
And before I went,
my wife said,
don't leave until you have a
breakthrough.
You're broken.
And I'm like,
I'm not broken and I haven't had a
breakthrough.
I'm saying,
so did you get broken or have a
breakthrough?
You know,
it's funny.
I actually know the answer,
at least the one that had some
breakthroughs for sure.
But I never felt broken.
And I think,
I think the reason I never felt broken
is because it had a definitive end date.
Yeah.
So
confer you would have been like,
I'm leaving.
Okay.
Would it be like.
Yeah,
it would have to really take me to a
place of,
you know.
Yeah.
I mean I had moments of being broken and
Super Sad.
I mean,
you know,
like when you're away from everything
and you don't know what's going on,
you just don't know.
You don't know God on my kids getting
bullied.
Is something happening?
Is My wife okay?
You know,
is the world in risk is just don't know.
And you start to imagine that the
world's going to end.
Your brain automatically goes to the
word.
It doesn't go to everything.
It's great.
It's like,
Oh shit,
I should've been so much nicer to my
wife because I'm going to go there.
She's not going to be home when I get
home.
Like you start sticking shit like that
and then it just spirals because you
have energy and space to think and
imagine and dream and envision and all
the shit that's like.
It all comes to the surface and you
know,
because it's in the real world.
If you're having a tough day,
you could say to Dave,
you,
you guys go,
you know what?
Let's put on a movie in my Netflix and
just fucking escape.
And you sit down,
you order Chinese food and you have your
Netflix and you'll watch it.
But guess what?
The issues don't go away.
When the movie's over,
that Shit is still there on your to do
list.
They're still there when I'm watching
that,
but they're still there and you know,
this forced you.
There was no escape.
This was your escape.
So it forced me to have to think through
stuff and I got a lot of clarity.
Although this is in no way comparable,
when I did my off the grid thing last
year and it for a week we were 10 days
or so.
We were in Mexico and I just,
I just needed to do nothing.
I just needed to wake up every morning,
have a light breakfast.
I went to the gym and then I would just
sit.
I got the same seat at the beach every
day and I would just sit and stare at
the ocean for hours really for hours and
I do try to do a little meditation and.
But I did have that moment at one point
where I was like,
anything could be happening right now
like world war three could be starting
their terror attack,
like a Zombie apocalypse.
Like where you go to like the craziest
shit.
And then I remember thinking,
I was like,
you know,
you go there for awhile and then I
suddenly got to the end of it and I was
like,
well,
nothing I can do about it right now.
So I better reset to this,
to this better place.
And there's a real discipline in that
in.
And how you can control your mind and
your thoughts.
I think for sure the first three or four
days there I was obsessed with my to do
list and by day four or five I'm like,
if a hurricane came and whisked my to do
list into the ocean,
life goes on,
like I'll be okay.
And you know,
I was,
I was like a captive to my to do list
because,
you know,
I'm always.
And it's my to do list for me,
it wasn't even about finishing the tasks
as good as I could possibly do.
Um,
it was about finishing up so I can keep.
It felt so good to cross them off that
even if it was 70 percent to what I
could probably do it.
Go onto the next,
onto the next,
at the monastery.
The monks only had to do list.
There was no to do list.
It was whatever is in front of me is my
task at hand.
So tell me a little bit just sort of
what that day looks like.
So you get up the next morning,
now it's day to day said,
did you say 7:00
AM or 6:00
AM?
Seven am.
And then prayer starts.
Yeah.
So they would ring a big,
a big like notre dame,
Notre Dame.
We like Church Val.
I was right next to which was the,
which signaled to go to the,
to the church where we would have a bad,
an hour and a half service.
Which was meditation,
reflection,
service.
What was it?
Religious in any way?
Yeah,
they were Russian Orthodox.
It was,
it was a religion,
it was religious for me it was,
it was peaceful,
um,
but it was definitely,
definitely religious.
And then,
and then we would shift to um,
breakfast which was traditionally
silent.
Most of those breakfast,
the breakfast we're silent and that
would go to,
let's say nine,
30 or 10 and afterwards there'll be a
little bit of alone time and then it
would go to tasks and each of the months
would have a different responsibility,
which was just unbelievably efficient.
And I spent each day shadowing a
different monks.
So I got two rounds basically.
Uh,
and then there would be supper.
Dinner was lunchtime,
so they flip flop.
So breakfast was a really light meal,
which for me is just fruit.
Then lunch,
their lunch was dinner.
That would be the big meal.
Rest or sleep away.
Camp you go,
the less time you will see us have more
labor,
which could be cleaning the church,
doing something,
whatever the everyone's tasks were.
They always have stuff to do because
it's like,
it's kind of funny,
like if you think about it,
like,
all right,
so eight guys living at this place,
you're always stuff.
Oh it seems like there wouldn't be that
much more to do,
you know,
because you don't want to know why.
If,
if the toilet breaks,
they don't call a plumber to fix the
toilet.
They built the monastery by hand.
They,
everything is,
they do everything.
Right?
Well let's,
let's get a swimming pool.
Okay.
Get a shovel,
you get a shovel and you get a shovel,
you know,
let's figure out how to do it,
and we'll build a swimming pool fees.
So they do probably hire you for a
couple of jobs.
Do anything.
I was a supervisor,
um,
and then,
and then we would,
there was just more time alone.
So there was a tremendous amount of
time.
Yeah.
But also a lot of work.
So talk a little bit about the
disconnecting from technology.
I get the concerns about your wife,
your kids,
things like that.
How did you feel about not putting your
hand in your pocket to go to your phone
or not having an ipad right in front of
you or television screen or the rest of
it?
You know,
it's funny because when I got back
everybody asks me,
well,
what did you miss?
The obvious answers I missed my family
and this and that,
but no one ever asked me what didn't you
miss?
And when I didn't miss at all were
things that I do everyday that I thought
I would miss.
For example,
I went during the NCAA tournament.
I didn't miss not watching March
madness.
It's been a pivot,
been something I've loved to do forever.
And if I calculated how many hours of
basketball I've watched,
it's like,
you know,
it's probably years of my life,
but I didn't miss it and I didn't miss
hitting like that,
you know,
liking my friend's picture and can Kuhn
with,
with a corona.
I didn't miss any of that stuff.
I didn't miss going through Hulu and
Netflix and debating with my wife what
to watch and I realized I spent a lot of
time on things that I really didn't
miss.
And if I eliminated some of those I
would freed up a lot more time to spend
to do the things I love to do with
people I love to do them with.
Yeah.
So,
but it was so comfortable with my phone
is always in my hand.
It was hard,
man.
Really hard.
It took,
it took a long time to get past that.
Did you feel that there was like a
little bit of a learning curve with it?
Like when I did it and as I said,
I locked my phone and a safe.
I did not know the code and I found it
for the first day or two.
I kept going in my pocket even at the
beach,
like I'm just going to be,
but there's nothing in my pocket.
I don't even think my shorts had
pockets,
so I was just like,
go like this.
And then there's like this weird anxiety
of like,
what's going on,
what did I miss is the Zombie apocalypse
or the war started or whatever.
And then suddenly by day like five,
I kind of felt empowered by day eight.
I was like,
I want nothing to do with that.
Then maybe there's a little bit of like
a return to a.
it'll be okay.
I'll manage it differently.
Did you go through all of the exact,
the exact steps that you just mentioned
in the exact timeframe you just,
um,
once I got to the point where I didn't
miss it,
where the habit of checking before I
went to bed or waking up at five in the
morning and seeing anything new come in
through,
you know,
once I got past that,
uh,
I just,
I didn't miss it.
I didn't want it,
you know,
and once I got home and I put on the
news and read,
you know,
like what's going on in the world and
all the negative stuff,
it was just like,
ugh.
But here I am,
I've been home and now I'm back on my
phone and I came home.
I'm like,
I'm off email and then you know,
but you drift back.
So
have you been able to put any kind of
just personal policies in place to
manage this stuff?
Because I'm still trying.
I don't do phone and bedroom 90 percent
of the nights.
Every now and again it just somehow ends
up there.
But like that's one for me.
So that at 5:00
AM I just
don't do that.
I've been the obvious ones,
you know?
No,
not in the bedroom,
not at meal time,
not in movies.
I'm and I used to sit and movies and I
heard a ding or a beep or a buzz.
I go into my shirt,
looked like the light to look under
here,
but now,
so there's.
So I became this.
I think this will summarize my
experience the best.
They had a retreat at the monastery and
they had all these guests and the guests
left.
They said to me,
Jesse,
you're going to clean up all the dishes
like the,
like the rookie on the team.
Okay.
There's 500 dishes stacked.
So I started cleaning the dishes and I'm
drawing.
I'm in cleaning up and drying them and
they go and they bring more in and I
turned to them.
I'm like,
I'm just going to take me forever.
How am I going to do all these dishes?
And one of the monks certainly goes,
there's not all those dishes.
There's only the dish that's in your
hand.
And I was like,
it reminded me that I'm never wearing my
feet are and I got to be where my feet
are,
you know,
this is what I'm doing.
Yeah,
there's something there because I do
find that I actually liked doing the
dishes.
I know that's a little nuts and I'm not
doing it for.
I'm not doing it for 500 people,
but I do find it's like one of like,
I can't have my phone in my hand while
I'm doing the dishes.
Right.
Like I,
it's one little thing that you're doing
right there.
So I do find on these brief moments
that,
you know,
I'm on tour right now and it's like when
I'm doing this,
when I have these brief moments,
I like doing very menial.
Like I really like gardening or just
like cleaning up outside or like these
things that aren't much because they
seem to have this incredible importance.
We've lost touch with a lot of those
things that help us feel connected.
You know,
like we have no connection to our food.
We go to a supermarket,
we didn't know unless you live on a
farm.
Like we're very disconnected from a lot
of things that make us tick and simple
things like that bring us back down to
earth and they ground us and I felt the
same way.
I felt up as a contributor even if it's
contributing to your own household,
you know?
And as opposed to having someone to come
in and clean it or however you guys do
it or whatever.
Um,
but it makes you feel connected.
Important part of it.
And uh,
it creates momentum and winds.
I can't explain it,
but I felt the same way.
I love it.
I was volunteering for it.
Yeah.
There's real value in that.
Like even when you came into my house
and you're like,
oh,
it's so great here and this and that.
And it's like I really love like we put
a lot of effort into like I want to like
wake up in the place that I want to be
at and like make it better and make it
more valuable than that.
So for the average person that can maybe
take a month to do this,
what's the piece of advice?
Or is it.
Can people do a weekend with monks?
Can you,
can you just do a day with me?
I think it.
Listen,
I think.
I think anyone could spend time alone.
Yeah.
I think spending time alone and you
reckon I recognize like I don't spend
any time alone other than going for
runs,
which is,
you know,
but I think it's really important
because I think the only way you can
really be in tune with your gut is to
spend some time alone.
So I think that's really important.
I think for me,
I carry a lot of stuff in my head.
I realized that I need to,
like I put everything on paper,
now I get out of my head,
it doesn't disappear,
but it frees up space.
I had a lot of space and creative energy
at the monastery because I didn't have,
I wasn't cluttered.
So now I have a two journal system that
I use.
It's very simple.
I dumped everything into one big
journal.
Doesn't go away,
but it's out of my head.
Yeah.
I don't have to remember I to get a kid
at birthday present or whatever,
and then I make my daily kind of routine
and,
and this kind of thing.
And um,
yeah,
I think just being really aware of where
your feet are is really important.
I mean the monks are Mano taskers.
I live in a world of multitasking and I
think that,
you know,
for the everyday,
for everybody I think that feels
overwhelmed or feel,
feels distracted,
is to do one thing at a time and do it
well and move on.
Have you been back to the monastery
since?
I'm going to go.
I haven't been back.
We're not planning on going to go back
to partake again or is it just like,
can you go like,
have lunch with them?
At least just for some high fives I met
like they're down for that sort of
thing.
Like the for some.
Yeah,
for some high fives.
I guess you'll figure it out.
I mean I was like an alien.
I came here,
I was full of energy.
I'm like,
oh,
like we're.
What are we running?
Did they,
did they have any idea of your history
or just,
you know,
your success is any of that stuff.
They just think it's just some guy.
Yeah,
we're letting in on this.
I don't remember.
That must've been pretty cool in and of
itself.
I remember very clearly sitting down and
I was telling him about my journey.
I was talking about coconut water and
they all looked at me and said,
what's going on?
What?
I was talking about the Atlanta Hawks
and one of them raised their hand,
said I went to an expos game,
well in Montreal,
and I'm like,
that's baseball anymore.
Like,
all right,
well for our last few minutes,
let's talk about the hawks for a second
and just own you own a basketball team,
which to me is,
as you know,
I love basketball.
Like that's like the greatest thing on
earth.
I would probably stop doing all this.
I would trade it in to own a basketball
team.
I'm,
I'm not the principal owner.
And uh,
we got a great group,
but for me living in Atlanta as a
basketball fan,
I was a season ticket holder for years
first.
And then I was a consultant to the team.
So I got to fall in love with the
players,
the coaching staff management first and
now it'd be part of the ownership group
with my wife and friends.
It's a in a city that I live in,
in a team that I love.
It's like,
you know,
it's just,
it's just unbelievable.
I was talking to my wife the other day,
I said,
you know,
from my father and my family and my
friends and the city,
there's 80 plus games a year where I
could put the tea nights a year.
I could put the TV on,
thinking about you as a knick fan,
multiply it by 20 and just,
you know,
as,
and just really love it.
So it's been super exciting and I think
we've got a really bright future.
So I'm looking forward to the next
couple of years.
I know it was a little before your time
of owning the hawks,
but how is Dominique Wilkins not in the
hall of fame?
I love Nick.
How's that kind of the whole thing?
He deserves to be.
He's a,
not only is he great basketball player,
but he's in Atlanta.
He's,
you know,
he's just a big part of the,
of the community.
So it's part of the state does the play,
but he's,
um,
he was at every game site.
I'd never seen him say no to a photo or
an autograph ever.
Never just,
um,
he makes people feel really good.
And uh,
he's very approachable.
Yeah.
What are you guys doing over there to
just
bring all of the things that you've
talked about here into the game and make
it fun and add some of the other stuff
that's not part of the 48 minutes?
Like,
you know,
the go New York go thing.
I think there's several buckets.
There's the internal bucket and Tony
Wrestlers the principal on.
He's done an amazing job of just,
we have a new practice facility that
state of the art best,
probably one of the best in the MBA.
Um,
we're renovating the arena.
Massive,
multi hundred million dollar renovation
that's going on now.
So there's a whole,
there's the internal stuff and then
there's the game presentation.
There's so many layers.
Game presentation.
There's the actual basketball side of
it.
There's the nights that the,
that,
that the team doesn't play that the
arena is available.
We have a concert,
I mean it's just,
there's so many layers of it,
but I think at the end of the day it's
said that enthusiasm and passion and
just bringing whatever you can to infuse
a culture of think of your emotional
connection to the next and the first
thing you said to me when I walked in
and you took me to 94 games,
you remember those.
I remember where I was sitting for a
certain games.
You know what you're eating and when he.
Five years ago,
I don't remember what I ate last week.
Right?
You have no idea.
There's just so much emotion and if we
could bring that same passion to the
community and marry that with the
Atlanta Hawks,
that's gonna be super powerful and I
think we can run annoying
man.
It's pretty clear you're bringing that
to your life everyday because this was
just.
I mean this flew by and it's like I
could feel it done.
That's it.
Well,
you got to go do Rogan now,
so I don't want to.
I don't want to steal all your brain
power.
You got three more hours with Rogan.
I sense you're going to be up to it to
the channel and you don't even drink
caffeine.
You're just hopped up on coconut water.
I am potassium down.
Protect.
You don't even need bananas anymore.
Do you have any.
Why would he have been at this point?
I eat a lot of bananas.
You eat the bananas.
Well,
listen man,
it's been,
it's been an absolute pleasure.
I suspect we will cross paths again
perhaps in Atlanta because even though
we're holding this for a little bit,
uh,
may come watch you.
All right,
we're going to come to the Peterson
event in Atlanta.
Awesome.
Uh,
for more on Jesse,
you can check out Jesse itzler.com.